hey guys Ryan right here today I am
finally doing it been getting asked this
since we had a few thousand Subs doing a
Q&A video that's right it's the Ryan
Wright show today it's all about me time
to tell you guys some truths I want to
start off by saying this though uh just
a couple of things first off uh we have
a cuz sorting through the comments can
be difficult when you're looking to give
shout outs to people so if you one of
those people who was requesting a shout
out or really wants one something like
that you can go to Facebook Facebook
facebook.com/ theal rejects
shoutouts yeah from now on we are just
going to be looking for the shout outs
there so if you if you really want one
you got to go there say something
interesting and then ask for one you
know just do that that's the requirement
you got to say something interesting no
matter what as long as it's interesting
in some fashion it could be like some
fact about Steven Hawk or it could be do
you shave your balls or not something
second thing I want to start off by
saying thank you guys I really do love
you guys a lot like this channel I
remember we first started it up like
there's so much faith in it I just love
the whole idea of doing YouTube like
it's you could just like get direct
interaction with fans and it's not
something you have to wait forever to
come out and you can just put it up
there and it just gets around to the
world like it's just so cool it's
genuine love of mine to do YouTube it's
like my little baby now it's my h my cat
this is my cat noise yeah I really do
appreciate the hell out of you guys I'm
not just saying that cuz I know a lot of
YouTubers say that the channel grows
like honest numbers the channel grows
like 2 to 300 subscribers a day now that
is so [__] trippy to me man I
remember when we were growing like one
subscriber a day now it's like two to
300 that it's it's just it's like I it's
hard to Fathom because people call
themselves fans and I guess technically
we have like fans but you really do just
view someone as a person and you're not
like you don't become aware like they're
a fan that is so strange to have
fans like it's [__] trippy but no
it's it's awesome and um I so I thought
like okay cool Q&A time and I'm going to
be just honest in these answers I I did
not prepare answers I'm going to try to
answer as many as possible if I don't
get around yours it's probably because
someone asked it earlier already but
yeah I just have the com comments Page
open I didn't select any specific
questions I'm just going to go right now
here we go David Melgar asked the first
question any other Melgar out there you
have met yes I was H best friends for a
while long time with this guy named
Brandon Melgar now we're just good
friends I wish he was my best friend
still maybe I'll get it to that way
Brandon if you're watching this I want
people to know you got to go meet this
guy at Spice Restaurant he owns best
French toast in Hollywood telling you
guys that right now off of Highland next
to Hollywood Bowl need direct actions
just message me on YouTube Rocket
Raccoon love you Rocket Raccoon you're
so cool not not just the character from
Guardians of the Galaxy like the
subscriber how many times would you suck
my dick on a daily basis uh four
alexavier Batista what's your favorite
scary movie Scream I really do like
scream a lot I should have thought of an
answer but I will say scream Ju Just For
Now there's a lot of great horror movies
though I mean does like cap fear the
dairo one categorize as a horror I don't
know alexavier Batista ask the last one
for from buttery beans what's your
favorite sci-fi movie Ryan and will you
still let me butter your beans haha
buttery beans I will of course let you
butter my beans my two beans they are
really small testicles apparently and my
favorite sci-fi movie um it's always a
tossup but I have to choose the Matrix
The Matrix or Terminator 2 but Matrix
just remember when it first came out the
visual effects were just like wao what
the [__] this is amazing they didn't new
things and then they got these stars and
they they they look like real martial
artists the action was unique the story
was so mindbending and philosophical it
was just the style was copied a billion
times no one was really satisfied with
the other two sequels I personally like
the Matrix Reloaded a lot and I like the
trilogy a lot as as a whole like when
you really study the whole concept the
all the real like the details it's all
in the [__] details that movie
[__] beautiful Ryan what are your top
10 films Matrix Kill Bill volume 1 and
two I'm the douche that encompasses them
that's just one movie I would have to
also say Terminator 2 American Graffiti
Dog Day Afternoon The Departed the Dark
Knight trilogy I com say has one Drive
road to predition and Anchor Man bam
Steve Jobs ass tits her
ass ass ass you know tits are like
something a woman is just born with and
they get big or they don't or and you
know and I'm not attracted to breast
implants knowing they're fake is a turn
off I'm an all natur all kind of guy
like my girlfriend Veronica so [__]
beautiful with or without makeup and I
prefer her without makeup I'm not just
saying that baby if you're watching I
[__] love you you're like the best
person ever you're my favorite human
being like I could cry right now but I'm
not going
to cuz I'm not a [__] in public but ass
uh my girlfriend's got a great ass and
it is all I mean don't get me wrong
her got to be a little bit of a
gentleman here her ass is fantastic and
because she works on it she works out
that ass she does her squats and [__]
bam see an ass is like if it's like good
it's because they worked on it you know
like I don't like them bony asses but
you know like firm so yeah ass is great
but boobs are just going to be boobs you
know they only change if they get if
women get fat or not but or get pregnant
you know boobs are just boobs ass is
something that could be a part of your
character jiggly jelly ask a lot of
questions let's see which ones are going
to be appropriate do you dress your
penis and costumes don't lie to me yeah
uh usually in like I I like to tattoo it
like henna but with like the Spiderman
color uh will you dress in woman's
clothing don't get sassy with me yeah
I've done it before it's not a
comfortable experience actually and I'm
not just saying that will you karaoke
with anyone and post it yeah I'm
actually planning on doing that have you
ever thought of doing a movie with Jerry
I think my dick is hard uh good for your
dick I have yeah no there's trust me
like there's like these fun short films
we just like randomly cooked up and
we're like let just shoot it right now
that we have on the channel and uh we're
going to be uh re-releasing two horror
films we did that from years ago that
are uh well we were definitely definely
just aspiring filmmakers we've already
done scripts together there others we
have an outline for a comic book we want
to do like we got a lot man we got a lot
in the pipeline are you happy or
satisfied with the way life has turned
out and how is it looking in the future
I am pretty happy you know like I'm
content yet I'm not content like I'm
kind of that guy who's like I really am
appreciative for what I have going on
but I still want more uh I'm a greedy
American that's how I put it it's all
about money making money more money this
is a Q&A video no jokes this time money
is the key they say money is the root of
all evil [__] being broke is the
root of all evil lack of money is the
root of all evil I am who I am based off
the dollars in my bank account which is
in the negatives right now Marcelo Prolo
he said ask me something uh why didn't
you come up with a question Smiley 179
movies you like but everyone hates I
like a lot of movies that everyone hates
just this year alone there was
Transcendence I think last year was
Hansel and grle witch hunter I like the
Halloween movies by Rob Zombie I like
Dumb and Dumber so yeah there's a lot of
films actually movies you hate but
Everyone likes they can tell you movies
I've seen that I don't care for but I
don't hate them
castleblanca not a big fan of
castleblanca seen it three times and I'm
like okay I don't hate it I don't even
dislike it I just don't believe that a
lot of people who answer cassablanca as
their favorite movie really feel that I
go based off my
feelings
[__] filmmakers who like so goddamn
analytical n picky
about at this point in the movie The
Writing should have gone like this [__]
you guys I hate those kinds of
filmmakers and no one likes them what
type of music do you listen to Johnny
Lingo what type of music do you listen
to too I really like uh Red Hot Chili
Peppers I love Eminem I Love Black Keys
Jack White's awesome as [__] Of Monsters
and Men Muse it's mainly a lot of bands
awall nation France ferdinan that's one
of my favorites for sure mmore is great
I don't have any black rappers on there
I don't know why my guilty pleasure is
Britney Spears you get in the car with
me we can blast the Britney tunes and I
will be able to s along with most of
them Anthony Smith if you could visit
any fictional world or place for a week
where would you go and who do you take
with you it could be a place from a book
movie TV video game Etc I would visit um
the True Blood world that would be
pretty [__] cool and I would want to
be turned into a vampire and then I
would uh turn Veronica into a vampire
that way she'd uh she'd be with me she'd
be my Prodigy I'd be her maker I am your
maker then I could say [__] like Su as
your maker I command you to strip I
could glamour people you do want to give
me a box of donuts for free bill that's
my Alexander scars guard Eric that's my
impression of him bill every line I say
is like this and ladies think I'm sexy
Su I am vampire suie bill I [__] hate
you Bill I [__] love you Bill D I met
Anna pin the other day she's [__]
cool Cameron Owens do you get paid for
your videos if you do you should let me
know because I like money and making
videos Cameron Owens d dude I am rolling
in D man I am just so rich that I don't
want to move out of this apartment I
could buy a house with all the money I
make the millions of dollars that comes
from 30 something thousand subscribers
it is cool this Scarface poster was not
a hand me- down this Scarface poster
it's authentic cost
$50,000
$50,000 the camera I'm recording on
$40,000 that's right my Scarface poster
is more money than my [__]
camera I make a lot of money Frylock
what is an actor actress you dislike I
cannot stand uh Peter sarsgard sleepy
eyes everything I say I'm just asleep
what's your favorite beer brand Negra
Modello cats or dogs um God I love both
uh dogs circumcised or uncircum
circumcised what do you think I in
Jew ah shout out to all my Jewish
subscribers favorite cereal uh Fruity
Pebbles dick or sack I would have to
suck a dick movie you think is overrated
oh Frozen Do you still find Adam Sandler
funny yeah I do can I get another shout
out I lost mine Frylock you got a big
[__] keep your [__] in stock that's
right they're replaceable cuz you're
capable of having a dick that will
forever be stable fly as goneo will you
make any more little skits in the future
and please let this be in the Q&A
because I'm going to be in surgery in a
week I at least want to be in my
favorite YouTuber's video but if it
doesn't I understand wow I feel like a
douchebag this comment came in on
September 26th and you've already had
your surgery but
hey shout out to you buddy Li is gone yo
you
yo oh yo I I just oh no I feel bad also
guys I'm a little sick so this is going
to be part one I'm going to do part I'm
going to release them once a week part
two coming out soon yeah this was just
the intro some of these questions get a
little bit more risky I'll heal up
throughout the week bam you guys will
even get a better video but thanks for
tuning in to part one hopefully there's
just a part two if if I could just do
one more video instead of dividing them
up that would be way
better